my name is cow and when this night and
when the moon
is shining bright and when the men have
gone to bed
i stay up late i lick the bread i love
that
hello and welcome to she doesn't read
the news with me chris turner
and me alice it's my wife hey wife
hello um it's we're we're still in
colorado it's been
it's been snowy it has yeah it's snowy
although not as snowy as it is in new
york i
haven't oh because your mother's been
complaining about how in new york
they're getting all the snow and you
can't even ski in new york um i saw a
picture
on instagram of someone skiing in new
york wearing skis
through as in manhattan yeah because we
are falling into the
thing that i'm sure new yorkers as in of
the state hate which is when we refer to
new york as
just manhattan but really it is guys
it's just manhattan
um so they were skiing through the town
yes exactly we'll call it a town because
then that damps down our
love of it yes exactly new york times
and as always you know i get all of my
news from instagram
discover page uh so it's the elgin
marbles back in greece yet
yeah last week that happened uh yeah so
it's sort of mixed in with my like
nail varnish adverts and
um like russian women with hair down to
their knees
explaining about how they get their head
do they have really short torsos
we should we should talk about my
instagram discover page because this has
been a saga for about four months
so okay a while ago let's explain that
instagram discover page okay
some people aren't on instagram um you
guys instagram is a dark place
and there's this discover tap where if
you click on that um the algorithm just
shows you a bunch of things it thinks
you'll like
so for me that's mainly um pictures of
russian women with very long hair and
nail varnish as said the discovery page
throws up what it thinks you're going to
like so one day uh kristen are
hanging out and i just decide i want to
see what's on his discover page to
compare
so i get him to pull up his instagram
and i click on his discover page and it
is nothing but
buxom yoga women wearing yoga pants
buxom is is the word right like think of
tolkien-esque not talkingness because he
didn't he doesn't put women in any of
his things no i don't think talking
about like like final fant not final
dungeons you're thinking like yeah
barmaid wenches yeah yeah
buxom wenches they were absolutely
successful you know it's either
oktoberfest or
a medieval fantasy sure but instead they
were all wearing yoga pants
very thin fabric yoga pants it was
pornographic
yeah like full-on these women are going
oh i did my squats this morning you're
like what you mean is
you did an exercise that shows off your
plump labia
not in a derogatory way like a plump
labia is a
that's a nice labia all labia is nice
labiaplasty has been on the rise
women you do not need to change how your
labia look
chris my god now that these women have
heard from you they're not going to need
to have any plastic surgery we are it's
20 21 but we are still in the place
where if a man says a progressive
statement
he still gets cookies exactly thank you
for all those cookies wow thank you for
speaking out
marilyn manson is a bad person oh chris
you're so good
well that was some news this week that i
wasn't going to put in but um marilyn
manson uh
rachel evan wood evan rachel woods um
from
she's in westwood she was in 13 she's
very beautiful um well so she dated
him when she was very like 19 he was 35
and she's
spoken about abuse she suffered in her
past and never named the person then she
named him this week
oh rachel wood yeah sound and
people are kind of looking back at
things he said in his autobiography
where he's like
every day i dreamed of smashing her head
in with a sledgehammer and everyone was
like
crazy marilyn manson it's like motley
crue in their book the dirt which is
a wild read if you want to learn about
the excesses of rock and roll and hair
metal in the 80s
they have a story in there about
being at a party and like one of them is
having sex with a girl in a closet
and then he likes like oh be back on one
second he goes and gets like his band
mate he's like hey go in there and have
sex this girl in my closet just say
you're me
and he goes in and then they talk about
how once that guy had finished
he goes out gets a random guy from the
party this is a horrible
closet yeah this is like this is like
what zeus always did in the myths
he would disguise himself as actually
king arthur did this too
but yeah uh no not king arthur king
arthur's father uh uther pendragon
anyway the point is historically this is
a thing that men do um
whenever they haven't disguised
themselves as a bull and the woman's
like oh because i wanted to have sex
with this bull and then afterwards the
guy's like haha i'm actually a man
you're not a bestiality person they're
like no i want it to happen
i think you're conflating several greek
myths here um but
back on marilyn manson just for a second
yeah uh i
i don't understand how because i have
asked several people from different
countries if
when they were in school they heard the
story about
oh marilyn manson removed one rib so he
could suck his own dick
everyone in the world has heard this
story yeah which is an adaptation of a
story from the 1980s i think to do with
mark almond who was the lead singer of
soft cell or
it was it was a story that origin no it
was like prince i think before then
mark almond i think was the guy who went
to hospital
and they pumped his stomach after a drug
overdose and they found the semen of
eight men inside that was the urban
legend there and as someone pointed out
i think my richard herring and the
comedian pointed out
if they found such a quantity of semen
they were then like this looks like more
than one man
let's test it like so obviously it's a
lie but i think this was a story about
prince first or even michael jackson and
then it became a marilyn manson story
but it's just funny because it's like
every single school child in the world
heard this story at some point i don't i
don't know how it made the rounds and
urban legends are interesting the way
they speak
pop star now that we can apply it to you
know
i think we're too out of the loop
hopefully hopefully like someone in your
discord will tell you
so just to finish up your instagram
discover page story so
alice kept pressing the pictures of
these books and wenches yes
which meant they kept appearing more and
more right now i think and i contended
this was never on mainstream discover
page i was like they are trying to hook
me in they're like well he doesn't go to
instagram's cover page
what if there's fit ladies i'm not
saying i don't like looking at fit
ladies and these were
fit late big big big bottoms and
then about two weeks ago i went to my
discover page
entirely cats just cats just cats i was
like wall-to-wall cats
see and that wasn't through a prolonged
campaign of me every time i see a cat
thing being like like oh god
unlike unfollow all these bucks and
wenches it instagram's gonna load well
we didn't catch him in with the the
hotties so we'll try the next
sexiest thing and i was like yeah give
me those kits
so um you know obviously though i am
only
liking the photos of cats in yoga pants
well of course
yeah we've been both of us led by you
really getting into a blast from the
past
in the form of bred lick poetry red look
poems
are from 2016 and
they are i i i they're they're highly
formulaic
poems so they have a regular rhyme
scheme
they're an ionic diameter so ionic
pentameter is the one everyone's
familiar with that's the shakespeare one
it's
so fine and fair today i have not seen
uh what's the tennison one to strive
to seek to find and not to yield there
we go yeah
um so that's pentameter iambic diameter
is but um
so two pentameter five so the story
between
behind uh bred like poems if you haven't
heard about them is that on a reddit
board someone posted a story about how
their uncle
like ran a bread factory in an 18th
century building
and a health inspector came and was
complaining about all the 18th century
building
just saying you did say bread factory is
that not a thing bakery
last week we discussed this but it
didn't make the podcast in greece at the
moment
there is a bit of a a problem with greek
people
using english words instead of making up
greek words and one of the words they've
decided to use instead of the greek word
for bakery which has lots of x's in
uh they now say bread factory so that's
why it's in your head clearly
but i think bread factory sort of works
anyway the point is so the health
inspector had just about let him
decided to let him off on all these kind
of old-fashioned elements of the bread
factory and then when he went outside to
where the loaves were stored he found a
cow licking the loaves and the uncle was
just like
listen this never happens and the health
inspector passed
the inspection and then someone on
reddit
wrote a just just perfect
poem in response to this chris would you
do this oh yeah my middle english so
alice delivers them in middle english
which i think they basically they're
written phonetically but it sounds like
middle english yeah
it's kind of like does speak but it
looks like it's not like
speak at all i think it's very different
than basically so uh
my name is kao and when this night and
when the moon
is shining bright and when the men have
gone to bed
i stay up late i lick the bread i love
them i think these poems are perfect
so it's bred lick because of that and
alice has been talking about these for
quite a while
as a side note i did a little bit of
googling about bred lick
and last year someone wrote an article
about
a.i trying to train it
to compose bred like poetry and it
couldn't do it
if they gave them like three words to
make the poem from and
it struggled with rhyme scheme it
struggled with number of lines and and
number of like syllables
some of the poems were very fun but just
because it's like
i'm relieved to hear that because and
i'm relieved as well because my job is
making rhymes a different robot
you know i've worked with people who are
involved with ai freestyle rep
like and they suck they're like oh we're
gonna make the robot do the rap and i'm
like oh
i do not have to worry maybe from other
people who are you know
very talented or rap or whatever but
robots know well romney's gonna take the
jobs but not for now
well they do get better sort of at an
exponential rate though so probably in
two years we'll both be [ __ ] yeah that
is true
that's true um i'll be i'll be here this
it won't be us it will be
two robot versions of this hello hello
welcome to she doesn't read
i do read the news we both know all the
news
but bradley poems i i just i love them
because i
love how structured they are and i love
that they're written essentially in
middle english
and i just think they're great i just
love them
they are they're lovely um if you're
watching on youtube comment with your
favorite bred lick poem if you're
listening
recite your favorite bradley poem into
the void
so let's get on with the news you still
don't read the news
i do not but i'm sure i'm sure you're
aware of the big one this week
covid stimulus oh
which checks the 1200 checks that people
got sent
earlier yes in like april to last us
until now
the ones that we've been living off
prosperously for all these months so joe
biden
is pushing forward with his stimulus
package his package is 1.9 trillion
dollars for me just for you wow
um 1.9 trillion the problem is he wants
to govern bipartisanly he wants
republicans to be on board with
everything he does because like we gotta
heal this nation
obviously republicans do not want to
spend 1.9 trillion it's a lot of money
they're worried about
inflation they're worried about the debt
so they were a group of republicans went
to the white house said hey how about
600
something billion and biden's like
that's not enough
i'm gonna do it without you all so
what's happening now is biden's just
gonna forge ahead
with a 1.9 trillion plan which you know
the the pete what people worry about is
that a lot of the stimulus checks aren't
targeted they're saying look you're just
giving people who don't need it and
there was a
think tank who said a lot of this money
is just going to go into savings
accounts a lot of this money's
not going to be spent in the economy but
isn't it supposed to only go to people
who earn under a certain amount
under a couple under 150 000 which is
the vast majority of america right
that's a lot you have to earn a lot of
money to not afford it
and even then it's ramped down after
that limit right it's not like you
cut off it goes down um republicans are
pissed about it they they had a vote um
and the democrats are going to pass it
through a thing called budget
reconciliation which means you don't
need
60 votes you need 51 votes in the senate
which they can get
so in the senate um no republicans voted
for the package
no one's voted for it in the house
i i'm reminded of two things
um first do you remember who which
president it was who
um just completely got rid of all
american debt
no i didn't there was a there was a
president i i can ask you to google it
but i think it was andrew jackson
1835. i knew it was andrew jackson
country was debt-free lasted one year
yeah it was andrew jackson and he paid
back all the debts do you know how much
all the debt was how much was all the
debt 75
million dollars that's a lot more money
in 1835 there's a lot more money
that was probably all the money i've
said this before but andrew jackson was
kind of like
uh early 19th century trump as in
when andrew jackson came to office
everyone was like what the [ __ ]
he's not presidential he's not like a
normal president he's a crazy man he's
gonna be so
different from the presidents that we've
had before uh and it's funny because now
we kind of look back on him and he's
just like considered
a president by most people um but
yeah he paid back all american debt and
it kind of didn't make it so it lasted a
year
it said the the thing about debt is that
um
on such a large scale i think we think
of it as um independent like individual
debt right where it's like well if i was
in
a million dollars of debt i i should try
and not be in debt as soon as possible
um that i had a friend describe it to me
as like she was like imagine you're a
vampire who lives forever
um and you take on a huge amount of debt
to live in a nice house
like that debt with like a low interest
debt
where you can pay it off over the course
of your forever life
that's kind of more what our country's
debt is like i don't know very much
about um
anything but i i do think that the
republicans are very very deeply
concerned about the debt
and it seems to me that this may be
because they view the debt as if america
is a person
with debt rather than understanding the
difference between
how debt works on a large permanent
scale with a country
then again maybe that's a really
patronizing thing for me to say i mean
my
feeling is that the argument of well
this money's not going to go to the
people who most need it
is a bit disingenuous because i think in
an ideal world for them
they wouldn't give the money to anyone
they'd be like well you know
you guys should have saved up some money
or thought about this you know i don't
know but 1.9 trillion
there's gonna be some money uh hopefully
it helps
i don't see how sixteen hundred dollars
really
it probably doesn't some cities but uh
the second thing this made me think of
when you talked about how biden was
trying to um
gotta keep bipartisan by yeah trying to
rule about
bipartisanly biden partisanship is what
i'm branding it
uh and how that hasn't really worked out
is it it reminds me a little bit about
how when abraham lincoln
was elected uh in 1860
so what we've learned so far from the
first three episodes of this podcast is
alice does not read the news but knows a
ridiculous amount about american
presidents for some
vague reason that i'm not quite sure of
is this because you read a weight but
why
article about presidency it's not it's
not because of that i am teaching the
civil law at the moment uh but yeah so
he's
so he's elected um yeah i guess it must
be 1860
end of 1860 he's elected and um and i
think a lot of people know this already
abraham lincoln specifically says
that he will not abolish slavery in his
uh i think it is inauguration speech
because he was like i think the most
important thing
is for the union to be preserved so the
single most important thing to me is
that america does not go to civil war
and uh of course that's what a [ __ ]
president
missed all his goals big news story that
anyone listening to last week's episode
might have been like why'd you leave
that out it's because we recorded before
this new story happened actually
we are recording on a saturday today not
not on a sunday like usual so if
anything big happens on sunday and we
didn't talk about it everyone's going to
be like why didn't they talk about
the great alien attack on sunday are
these typical lefties
biased ignoring all that i mean let's
not lie we are
we are biased oh yeah of course that's
fair to say yeah no yeah i wouldn't
cover an alien attack even if it
happened i don't know why
you know hey let them come that's fine i
don't think we should have a space force
um uh was there was a a big old coup
a massive coup and i don't mean from a
large pigeon
i um i used to do a joke about i used to
think um
couplets were just tiny military
takeovers
there was a coup in myanmar and
you know after a couple of years of
having uh
a democratically elected leadership led
all kind of by answer she not really
because she was the military banned her
from running for office but she leads
she's the civilian leader they had a
coup they've
put her under house arrest allegedly
still no one knows
um and sangsu chi for those of you who
don't know
very interesting story so she started
off seeming like
the savior of myanmar we should point
out people in myanmar
pretty much treat her as a saint or a
goddess she's like it's
a buddhist country and sangsui is held
in such high regard she was the daughter
of a great
leader or military person anyway um she
moved abroad grew up uh in the uk uh
went to
oxford university went to my college
well they yeah they had they got
big old paintings
nobel peace prize winner she won the
nobel peace prize because she was under
house arrest for like
so many so many years like 15 20 years
um
because she was like i i don't like the
military uh the
rule myanmar now obviously this is all
as a byproduct of the fact that myanmar
was owned by britain until 1948.
was it awful i think it was the empire
yeah whoops
back when it was called burma um still
most americans would call it burma
burma is the official name for it in
america oh really
but i think in myanmar they don't like
for you to call it but um
it's because burma is referring to the
burmese the main ethnic group there
right
and then the the military in the 60s
were like
no we can also refer to this country as
myanmar and that's the more
like formal way and like we're going to
be more formal more formal about it so
you know it's it's that kind of thing
like when i was in mumbai
i was performing at the bombay institute
of information technology
but i think mumbai and bombay is one of
those things where it's like that's
colonial i can call me ugly you can't
call me ugly
i think that that's like if we call it
bombay that's
embarrassing because that was the
british term for it and then when it
became
independent it was in mumbai but i i had
a lot of people
in mumbai tell me oh no it's fine you
can call it whatever you want i was also
told there that no it's fine
the audience will love it if you do an
indian accent on stage i was like oh yes
but uh
i would not so uh i just did a welsh
accent which sounds indian
it really does um so i am listening to a
ken follow book narrated by john lee
called fall of giants which starts off
in a welsh mining town
and his welsh accents could do with a
bit of polish
i don't know if it's because i'm
listening to it on 1.25 i don't listen
to audiobooks on normal speed
um they they are straying a little bit
subcontinental a welsh accent is not
easy to do so she was
under house arrest won the nobel peace
prize and was held up as this
you know shining light of democracy
because she won
her party won election and then um
what happened was there was genocide of
the rohingya muslim minority
in myanmar and from what i know about
this
myanmar is a very buddhist country and
they do not
see the rohingya as um burmese they're
not they're not from that country they
don't think that at all
and so when the military were committing
genocide and sansuchi
stood up the military and said this is
not happening and she i think it was the
gabon
passed a resolution in the u.n and she
was like no
you don't understand you're not you
don't understand the goings-on of our
country
she didn't say the term rohingya she
didn't want to even like humanize them
in that way
and she has refused to accept that this
is happening it's about the fact that
it is happening and some people were
like oh does she really want to be in
with the military that much because the
thing is the military still control
myanmar they even when there was a
democratic government like the military
as we've seen could do whatever they
want to because they're the military
right they just have the power and
they've said oh once we've settled down
there'll be some free and fair elections
but um they you know they've cut off the
internet oh
god can you do that that's how that you
know when there's a coup the reporters
in myanmar were like wait
is there a coup and the internet was
down they were like oh that's a coup
and now they've put everything facebook
instagram everything because people were
using it to start protests
and their protests consist of um honking
car horns and banging pots and pans
and doing the hunger games salute that's
become a
the little three fingers up in the air
because you're fighting back against
you know the powers of you say if you
are suzanne collins
that's a kind of i mean move over fan
fiction
you know having your thing in your book
become a
symbol of rebellion in myanmar is pretty
cool
yeah i did see uh one of the champs
they're using now i'm sure that in
whatever language they speak in myanmar
it's a beautiful chant
however translated this is what they
have been chanting
military dictator fail fail democracy
win win that's just bad translating
that's an unpoetic translator is the
internet still offer
internet is still off yeah so sadly
they're not listening to our
corruscating analysis of what is going
on
cora skating's a good one is a good word
yeah my school reports my english
teacher always used to use a different
obscure esoteric word to describe me
so it would be every every term of
anyone and my favorite ones were
an iconoclastic individual which i then
looked up it was like oh wait
literally means burning and destroying
religious idols well it means it means
you're irreverent
i like that thank you in that you're not
a reverend because the reverend wouldn't
do that
so i think coruscating chris is
corresponding insight on the gcse
syllabus
he was just mocking me yeah he also
liked me a lot though he was a really
good teacher i liked him a lot cheers mr
dean you are ace
we mentioned ai up top ai story this
week
and an aoc story it's a combination
of two amazing things is it like letters
deep fake of her or something
it's it's a depressing one it's a
depressed so we know that ai
and algorithms are very sinister
yeah unbiased right like they're racist
they are sexist i think amazon
in 2015 figured out that their algorithm
that was like
monitoring applicants to work there was
filtering out anyone whose resume
included the words
women's like women's rights and they was
like well we don't want that
troublemaker here
off your trot um so what's happened is
these scientists did a study
where they were like hey this ai we're
gonna train it on
pictures of people and then we're gonna
feed it images of
just a head like just a face with just a
neck and then we're going to ask it to
fill in below the neck
and if you gave it a picture of a man 43
at the time the man would be in a suit
and the rest of time in clothes if you
feed it
ahead of a woman 56 of the time
she comes out in a bikini or a low cut
top well that is my natural state
i mean yeah this is where we have to
film from the neck up here
um we know deep fakes and all this
stuff's can be a problem
but the the controversy was that the
scientists published this paper
saying look we did one of aoc and it
came up with hair and a bikini
with this fake picture of aoc in a
bikini and everyone was just like well
one this is
bad news but also two why the [ __ ] are
you doing that
yeah and the scientists immediately were
like oh we're so sorry we'll get rid of
it sorry
to do um
that is that is depressing but not
surprising
no because if you feed it on an image
set of women on the internet
yeah like i i have been using a lot of
stock footage for my
my videos recently yeah and if you
search
you know old woman the oldest woman i
could find stock footage on this website
was
55 60. oh well they don't exist yeah
yeah i mean
for the derriere video the french one i
was looking for like sexy bottoms all
those bottoms were white bottoms
and then even when i was like looking
like oh i want some diversity in my
bottoms right
i found like one one piece of stock
footage with someone who was
vaguely not white this episode is
getting quite uh
empiry because i have a story from hong
kong now
so hong kong we've been having mad
protests there for about a year and a
half two years based
on uh the chinese mainland attempting to
make it closer to china because china
claims hong kong is china
hong kong says hong kong is hong kong um
and
again all goes back to britain we we got
hong kong
in i think the first opium war which
tell us about the opium war alice
because that sounds like a bomb
jiggety war i'm sure you know about the
everyone knows about the opium
well some people listening may not know
about the opinions so um the only thing
i know about opium is that
a guy from my school in the last day of
school
brought in some opium and was like i'm
gonna smell this opium and we were like
what a weird drug and then he smoked it
he was like
yeah it's pretty cool tastes really bad
like are you sherlock holmes
yeah i think that's very romantic um so
[Music]
yeah so um at the end of the 18th
century
everyone wanted stuff from china right
because you could get um
porcelain and tea and silk but china
wanted literally nothing from anywhere
else in the world and like there's this
hilarious and
like letter from one of the emperors to
um
the british envoy i think where the
envoy had come his name was mccartney he
came
towards the end of the 18th century and
um the envoy gave him some gifts and
then the letter basically responds along
the lines of
we accepted your gifts because it would
have embarrassed you if we hadn't
but we really didn't need them because
we have everything that a country could
ever need
so obviously britain was getting really
pissed off about this because it was
starting to rule
the world and china was acting as if um
britain was this like little tribe of
barbarians and so
they just got everyone in china addicted
to opium
just like literally just got them
horribly addicted to opium
because they could grow opium in india
uh and the middle east and then
maybe not the middle east but anyway
they could grow opium and afghanistan
is like a huge poppy field
yeah center don't know what british
control of
afghanistan looked like in this time
period because i think they had some
wars in afghanistan
in the second half of the 19th 19th
century but anyway so the point is
so um and i don't think this was exactly
a government
operation but it was clearly sort of
sanctioned by them it was okay with the
government
so finally um and this is getting really
bad
uh like in the the province around
uh i think it was called canton back
then i don't know if it's still cook i
don't think it's still called canton
uh in in the province around canton like
something like 90
of people in canton were addicted to
opium um
so it was it was getting really bad
and so um the emperor's like
aide whose name i can't remember but i
think it was lin
or something lin uh which we've had an
envoy called mccartney and now we've got
an aide quite sure it wasn't lenin's
and lynn basically seized all the opium
uh i think in well 1839 and he seized
all the opium
and uh burnt it but not just because if
you just burn the opium everyone
would have gotten high on the theme so
he burnt it with
uh he added like sea water and like
bracken
and he completely made it gross and he
burnt all of it and obviously the
british were like furious
because this to them seemed like an act
of war because he burnt like
millions and millions of pounds worth of
opium and
this is like the um i think it was in
kenya to stop
the ivory trade the new guy who came in
like minister for smuggling came in and
was just like
hey all this ivory that you keep
smuggling watch this and then he just
burnt it
all wow but that sends a message doesn't
it oh it did yeah
i mean upset some elephants
i was really looking forward to being a
pen holder who needed a spare tusk
um so so he burns all of this opium
and the british declare war and the
first opium war happens and
unfortunately the first how many were
there there were two opium wars
and it's bad times for china so the
problem are you interested
yeah i'm interested okay so the problem
i hope you guys are interested if you're
not
[ __ ] you and this is a great thing i
know all of this from my mother my
mother is much more knowledgeable than i
am
because she is obviously an expert on
opium
addicted i think opium needs to make a
comeback right it's quite like you know
like
heroin cocaine they've had their moment
in the spotlight
opium guys like it really is it's so
authentic you know people like i want
all these old-fashioned style kind of
cocktails and hipster bars people need
to start doing opium
china doesn't really have very many
enemies that it needed to fight at sea
so it really didn't have much of a navy
that it had built and also it had been
so secure
in its sort of superiority for just
centuries
that it just hadn't spent much time
focusing on
defensive weaponry or even offensive
weaponry like these these
ships that they were sending out against
like british steamships were equipped
with many
bows and arrows and this is the country
that invented gunpowder yeah i don't
really understand it and the invented
gunpowder and were like oh let's just
use this for fireworks because
you know who who's going to fight us
like oh good idea yeah well i do think
that if you look at the position of
chinese
china it's very well sheltered by sort
of mountains etc and water
there's a theory called the great
divergence theory which is basically
trying to understand
why china seems to have fallen behind
technologically during the
renaissance because up until the
renaissance it was just a hundred
percent ahead of everyone
all the way through history and then
somehow at the renaissance it kind of
just didn't keep
doing that i don't know very much about
this theory it's possible that this is a
eurocentric theory
that is problematic i don't know but the
point is the chinese were not well
prepared um to fight the british navy
which at this point was just the the
finest navy in the world
and so the british gained um i think
they gained hong kong at this point
and they uh operated a series of unequal
treaties and then
this began what is known as the century
of humiliation which goes from
1842 to 1814 to 1949
which was just bad times for china for
100 years
the century of humiliation it's great it
sounds like the new 50 shades of grey
novel
it does yeah so hong kong you know uh
we've
britain has kind of had sway over it
since roughly the first opium war i
believe
hong kong uh introduced these new
anti-democracy
laws no they don't call them that um but
essentially it's
to stop and punish any seditions to
session or collaboration with foreign
agents
with life in prison so this has stopped
the protests because they're like he's
going to go to jail a lot of
the leaders left the country um i think
a lot of
britain is opening up a visa scheme for
hong kong citizens
who want to resettle which is a good
thing that they should have done with
you know every other country they made
it's one of the things that i find just
so horrid about
britain and all the kind of pro brexit
arguments that were to do with stopping
immigration
it's like these people want to come to
britain because we took over their
country we forced them to
like britain and we're like hey you
should be more like us because we're
great
right and then when they were
independent they're like hey we'd like
to come to you and they're like
jog on they've introduced these laws in
hong kong and
schools in hong kong have just launched
a campaign
fronted by a cute little cartoon owl
to educate children on why these laws
are necessary children as young as
six and from that stage these children
are now being monitored
by teachers they've been instructed to
monitor them for any
pro-democracy leanings that sounds like
such a miserable job as a teacher can
you imagine
like someone's like oh but why do we
have to be like china well you are
actually going to jail now
like that that's imagine that like yeah
and with a cute little owl they are
misusing the cuteness and wisdom of owls
and i love owls when we got married i
the first thing i said so we got the
venue we got the venue and then chris
was like
don't worry alice i've booked the owl
got the owl and i was like i'm sorry i
thought that that was something we joked
about two years ago
and he was like it's already booked
non-refundable deposit
spare owl comes with the spare owl two
hours because right the main hell but
the owl was there to deliver the rings
yeah it flies down so my best man
did a very funny bit where he pretends
to forgot on the rings and was like ha
ha
and then he produces a dead mouse and
the and
was like why is he got that and then
this beautiful
just so it's headwig just
down from the back with the rings he
gets rings he's like there you go gives
them to us everyone's like oh michael we
have pictures of the hour flying away
and like the face of one of your aunts
is just
just a gog a gog is the word
with just wonder like i am in a fairy
tale and obviously it was a fairy tale
because it was my own most beautiful
problem it was everyone thought this was
me being a total bridezilla
ah but it was me it was absolutely crazy
and so the spare owl was because that
owl could get a little grouchy
so we did some photos with the owl with
you and your wedding dress which it
promptly shut off yeah that was great uh
that was amazing obviously it was gonna
do that
uh no discount for that and then then he
got put away and then he had a funny owl
a album it was a stupid people could
pose for pictures with
it was like uh pigwidgeon it was no it
wasn't it
i mean it was just an owl of its own but
the point is
chris has a bit of an owl fascination i
love owls
one of my favorite players ever been was
kirk lee from owl sanctuary
which fun fact uh if you know the story
of beauty mcboatface which was the
yes the meme name given to a boat that
they didn't actually give the boat they
named the boat the sir david
attenborough and then they named the
light boat boating with boat faces
silly instead but that comes from an
internet meme
of an owl at kirk leetham our sanctuary
called uh called hootie mchootface
i see china are launching a campaign
to halt the feminization of
men men yeah yeah yeah well that seems
to be a concern so i read this um
amazing sci-fi series called the three
body problem which is
uh if you like sci-fi i'm sure you've
heard of it already
um and it was just like the biggest
sci-fi novel in
uh china um
and one of the things that happens in
in this sci-fi novel is and it spans
like billions of years
but something that the author talks
about is how
whenever times are good men start
becoming like women
and become like these incredibly elegant
beautiful angelic
carved creatures uh and then when things
are hard men look like man
men again um and i thought it was really
interesting because that didn't seem
like something that
you know writers in the west are talking
about in the same way
i think i think men everywhere basically
whenever there's not a great big war
going on
men are very concerned about their
masculinity and
i just think that the way they're
concerned about the masculinity in china
seems different from how they are in the
west and they do have all those
they do have highly feminized men in
like their popular culture the role
models in china you have to be
super squeaky clean right like someone
got hung out to drive because they were
smoking
it's very similar to the kind of k-pop
approach which is you have to be perfect
you have to be a role model and an idol
yeah
and so there's these very delicately
featured men
um and the government is annoyed with it
so they're saying are role models need
to be soccer stars they need to be
footballers because
that's a good masculine thing and you're
like i don't know david ginla
is one of the sexiest men of all time
he was a player who it was french it was
long beautiful hair he was in hair
shampoo commercials as a footballer
right david beckham think of diabetic
you know
like the kind of the innovation of
metrosexuality
beckham's quite isn't he quite masculine
i think he was the first metrosexual
like
him he took care of his appearance and
changed his hair whereas before then
footballers were like kind of
like shaving their heads or you know
whatever like he um
yeah dev beckham was the first
metrosexual i think um so
some of the the terms that have been
thrown around this uh
holding a feminization so they've said
boys
are increasingly weak timid and
self-abusing
and that feminization will inevitably
endanger the survival and development of
the chinese nation until it's
effectively managed
and one of the the main culprits these
celebrities
are referred to in a positive way by
their fans there's a word
the translator says little fresh meats
is what they call
young handsome men and so people are
i don't know i i find this this is a
country that
literally killed
girls right like china has a huge
imbalance of
of men and women like it has way more
men than women and i don't think any
other country has that
no you know no i do
so so it feels yeah it feels
particularly strange to then
wage a campaign on february look we got
rid of these women
and now the men are becoming women no
what are you doing
we'll leave you in a mountain side but i
think that it
it speaks to a as i said uh you know
whenever there's not a great big war
mannequin's own about masculinity uh
i i don't think that this is uh
surprising to me i don't think it's that
different from a lot of internet culture
which talks about how men need to be men
and train that
you know sort of start dating women who
are not
afraid to be women again you know and
it's we've really broken away from
a lot of more traditional gender roles
in the last 200 years and i think that
that's
uh you know that's a change it's it's
sort of scary and hard for people to
adjust to
okay so i'm not gonna let you talk the
rest of this podcast i'm gonna assert my
muscular name please do
shut up actually women secretly love it
when you don't let them have any freedom
our final new story for this week is a
good one
they've discovered in madagascar the
world's tidiest reptile
how small is it 22 millimeters
i can't that's 2.2 centimeters put like
on my nail
your thumbnail your thumbnail a lizard
that big
oh it's called the brocasia nana
oh and it is it is tiny it eats mites
from the rainforest floor and at
nighttime
hides in blades of grass predators i
wonder if
actually though if i were to see one i
would just think it was a horrible
insect i'll show you a picture it's
beautiful is it it's gorgeous i'm quite
fond of ripping it's a tiny tiny little
essentially chameleon i think i held a
gecko once and it was
just the best thing ever it's tiny so
it's sweet but it also
it also is an insect if it was on you
you would flick it away yeah
you'd be upset about it i don't i think
yeah i just think when animals are that
small it kind of freaks me out
that is that is the male the female is
longer
is 50 bigger um although it is wearing a
bikini
just full revelation that's the second
joke i've tried to make about that the
first one i tried to make about a link
to the chinese feminization it really
bombed so we put that one instead you've
got to put one joke about tiny
chameleons
i think that's a cute cute little thing
in it i don't know if i
i think it sounds cute but if i were to
see it i would think it was horrid
so you held uh what was it that you had
i think it was a gecko
a gecko and you said it was the cutest
thing it was it was just so wonderful
they're the ones with those little
sticky pads on their things
for anyone watching i'm doing gecko
fingers not a
anti-myanmar military salute no breaking
news this week there wasn't a news story
that was breaking enough today that i
thought there wasn't a single news story
like this i think you didn't look hard
enough i looked pretty hard i just
didn't find anything interesting i
didn't want to talk about it
um but we do have a segment now called
news that neither of us care about
tomorrow
what's happening tomorrow the one of the
biggest events in the american calendar
oh is it a football game or something
yeah it's a football game super bowl
i thought the super bowl was at
thanksgiving
no they just also watched football and
thanksgiving yeah they also watch
football on thanksgiving i think it
might be college games i'd like to point
out i was a cheerleader
yes oh my gosh check this out and so we
should clarify alice was at high school
in america
for a while and i uh i have seen
therefore
many football games and no one on the
cheer team
cared about football and so we were
constantly doing the wrong cheers right
we'd be like defense
defense and then the cheer coach would
run over and be like they're not on
defense
like the opposite team is on defense and
we're like oh offense
from what i understand america football
there are two separate teams when you're
attacking them when you're defending i
don't even [ __ ] care it's so
long i hate how it'll say on the clock
that there's 10 minutes left of the game
but there's not 10 minutes left yeah
that's an hour
there's yeah 45 minutes you you can't
why
i hate it so it's the super bowl it is
the uh the buccaneers
who are from somewhere tampa bay sure
uh against the kansas city chief the
kansas state chiefs were in the super
bowl last year
so they're still called the chiefs yes
is that a thing
several football teams are renaming
themselves right i can't remember which
one
i think the redskins now are just called
the washington football team and they're
going to rename it
yeah because because the chiefs is less
obviously
crass but uh i i think it's still not
the highest
i think because they're in kansas city
is in missouri
not in kansas really yeah it seems like
a mistake
yeah well because um last year when they
won the super bowl
trump tweeted out congratulations the
great people of kansas were in the super
bowl and everyone was like
that's not our state [ __ ] you are
the president of the united states and
you didn't know which one it was
um so they're they're in the final again
but um the tampa bay buccaneers
so i think if you knew one football you
would know this person do you know who
tom brady is
i think i think he's the same person as
tom hardy and he's not very different
people
tom hardy eats meat uh tom brady is a
very famous he's a vegan he's the vegan
and he has some
wacky ideas about like diet and how
a vegan diet is the best for any athlete
and with his plan that you pay money to
sign up for you can become really good
all i know about tom brady is one he's
married to giselle
okay he's the super fit supermodel he
used to be the date leonardo dicaprio
yeah
he plays bane no that's tom hardy good
good point and uh in the park a court's
album
wide awake at the end of one of the
songs the song total football
the song stops and then everyone just
sings and [ __ ] tom brady
why i think it's because he was involved
in a cheating scandal i think he used to
deflate the balls
to make them easier to hold so he could
then throw them further i loved him in
dunkirk
so what you get you getting confused
with tom hardy there right
who whenever i think of bane i think at
the time i was on a train
knox i think in rhymes with my uh comedy
friends and we all started doing bane
impersonations now
my bane impersonation was the weakest of
all my friends but essentially it's just
going
bad and someone walked up to our table
the four of us and we were like oh he's
probably going to tell us off being
annoying and he's away excuse me
are you doing bane impressions and we
said yes he went
cool
right as if you could be doing anything
else yeah it was just plain impressions
maybe he thought we were doing tom brady
impressions maybe he was very
very puzzled what's your news this week
what have you learned this week uh well
i've read a few things that i don't
think would be fun to talk about but i
thought i might tell you about edgar
allan poe's life
so um i think i probably have already
told chris this have i
you spoke to me a bit dumb details
so edgar allen poe uh he's famous for
um the raven uh which is his most famous
poem
and he also wrote a lot of um gothic
short stories right so
that's what he's famous for he's a
gothic writer normal short story but
with eyeliner
his parents were um actors and his
mother had moved to america from england
and i think he was born in 1809 and his
father walked out on the family
when he was one uh his mother died i
think of tuberculosis um
a year like very shortly afterwards and
so he's always trying to fit
tuberculosis
podcast all over the place anyway so
he was kind of sort of unofficially
adopted
by this slave and tobacco merchant
called john allen
so edgar allen poe was not called edgar
allen poes called edgar poe
and he took allen because he felt so
grateful to john allen
uh so he was raised for a while in
virginia and then
um when he was about six or seven they
moved to england for a while and they
kind of potted around
britain and he went to boarding schools
so formative years in britain which is
part of the reason his gothic short
stories are so often
set in like grand british castles and
then he moved back when he was 11.
and when he was 17 he went to the
university of virginia
which if you don't know it was founded
by thomas jefferson
so um it was relatively new at this
point
and there wasn't much structure and
edgar allen poe
just partied like mad and got into
serious gambling debt and he got into a
massive fight with john allen and john
allen was like i'm not going to pay your
insane gambling debt stop
gambling and i'd grandpa was like well
[ __ ] you and moved
to i think boston and tried to make it
as a writer but
no one was buying any writing by
americans because there were no
copyright laws so you could just steal
british literature like there was
nothing to stop you from just printing
out
pride and prejudice and selling that and
like not giving jane austen any money so
it was very cheap
to just use british writers and who the
[ __ ] would want to pay an american
writer so he
he couldn't make any money so at 18 he
um signed up to the army and he had to
lie he said he was 22. um and by the way
he's not the only artist who signed up
to the army out of spite samuel taylor
coleridge the romantic poet
uh got his heart broken and signed up to
go fight i think in the
like in against france in the french
revolution
and um he was not a fighting type like
he was very much uh there well i
actually know thucydides off by heart
he was an opium type right later later
not at this point um
and his brothers were like oh [ __ ]
samuel taylor coleridge
is gonna die and so they went and
convinced the army that samuel taylor
coleridge was clinically insane and
dragged him away from the army
uh but back to red girl and poe you know
he was in the army for a while but there
was only so high up you could climb if
you hadn't um
basically gone to west point so this is
the opposite training school yeah it's
sandhurst in england basically
um west point is that that's the one on
on a river
right it's on a river and it's like
george washington was like this is the
most important strategic
point in america yeah there's some
reason why they pick i think it's in new
york state
i think i think it is yeah it's like a
place that they it's like it was a fort
or something that they held
during the the revolutionary yeah and
like a lot of very famous people went
but
uh so i'd rather wanted to go to west
point and he actually reconciled with
john allen
the slave merchant father figure and um
went i like that you are preferencing
any mention of him with the fact that
he's a slave merchant unless we think he
was a nice person in any way
he let's not forget john allen massive
[ __ ]
not in that sense yes i'm not saying
maybe he did
it doesn't matter because if you are
that morally bankrupt doesn't matter how
big your penis is
no one will love you if you trade in
slaves and tobacco
ugh filthy man carry on so he went to
west point i want to say this podcast is
firmly anti-slavery
wow chris that's actually really brave
of you to say i'm hella progressive and
i don't i don't care about the flack i'm
gonna take in the comments
um so he went to west point and he was
not suited for west point i mean let's
it's he couldn't hack it at university
of virginia
because he was too much of a party
animal worse point was much much worse
so um he wanted to drop out of west
point also at this point um
john allen remarried a woman who i think
hated at grand po and cause
there was like another huge rift between
them although i'm inclined to believe
that any fight edgar allen grandpa was
involved with was edgar allen poe's
fault
uh so he decides he wants to leave west
point but at this
point in time uh you can't just leave
west point you must be court-martialed
out of west point
wow sounds like a challenge yeah so he
was
uh he managed to get himself
court-martialed by being disobedient so
he's court-martialed for disobedience
after having been disobedient and he is
uh you know expelled from west point and
he
moves uh away to i'd probably boston
again i can't remember
and um he wants to self-publish his
poems he's been publishing
his things all this time and no one
[ __ ] reads anything he has to are
they good
i he's aldis huxley who wrote brave new
world
described edgar allan poe's writing as
similar to a man who wore a diamond ring
on every finger
aka overwrought and tacky he decided he
wanted to self-publish a book of his
own poems and this i think is really
sweet um
he didn't have the money to do it
because he had just angered john allen
again
but all of his cadet friends
from west point chipped in 75 cents each
and he was able to self-publish a book
of poetry because of that which i think
is just very lovely
that's very nice i think the reason was
that one of the ways in which he was
disobedient
when would this have been this would
have been like 80 1832 well
yeah i just want to know how close we
are to andrew jackson canceling all the
deaths no right around then ready okay
well
everyone's like there's no debt anymore
we'll give him 75 cents here you go and
oh cheese guys 74 6 i'm so excited so
uh it's because so yeah they they they
supported his poetry career because one
of the ways in which he was disobedient
at west point was he wrote
these incredibly searing sarcastic
sartorial poems
not sartorial yes satirical satirical
poems
so satirically well-dressed he's a model
of satirical elegance
about all of their commanding officers
uh and i think that his poems were very
popular at west point because they were
nasty and so they thought
maybe you'd publish a bunch of funny
poems they were not funny they were dark
and gothic
so um he gets a job uh
editing at a newspaper um within a
couple of weeks had shown up incredibly
drunk and been fired
so he um went home to
marry his 13 year old cousin virginia
classic
now i hear you in the comments saying uh
actually he just procured the marriage
license when she was 13. he didn't marry
her
in a church until she was 14 to which i
answer
that's not better he was 26. this is a
this is and i know what you're thinking
you're like oh it's the it's the past
alice
i think what people are thinking is this
is the third episode in a row where you
brought up pedophilia i think it was
very common uh
so so uh yeah you might be thinking like
everyone in the past
married children in pride and prejudice
which is earlier than this
lydia gets married at 15 and everyone's
like that's quite young isn't it isn't
that quite young
so it is weird to go and marry your 13
year old cousin like even within the
time period it's a bit weird
um so he marries her and actually in
fairness the marriage was um apparently
quite lovely
but uh after a while you know he'd been
editor and actually oh yeah he managed
to get the job that fired him to hire
him again so he must have been
persuasive
and he did all right for a while if you
can convince a 13 year old to marry you
you can convince the newspaper to hire
you again he uh
he decided he wanted to work for the
president and he had an in with the
president who was john tyler
who i don't know anything about and um
his connection at john tyler's office
was like all right i'm going to give you
a job interview opportunity
just show up at this time this place and
i had to go out and po
got very drunk and did not go to the
interview and then was like can i get
the job
and obviously his friend was like no you
can't get the dr the job you
drunken lout meanwhile virginia has
uh contracted tuberculosis and is slowly
dying
and um at this point roughly he um
he writes the raven and sells it for the
princely sum
of nine whole dollars but that was a lot
of money it really wasn't that much
money
no uh so he sells it for nine dollars
and it becomes a smash
hit and he becomes like a best-selling
writer all across america but he i think
he really only saw
nine dollars of that money which is
frustrating virginia dies
she's in her early twenties dies of
tuberculosis and um
edgar allan poe starts drinking more if
you can believe it
more and uh finally
sort of not that long after she died um
when he was 40 he was found roaming
uh the streets of maybe baltimore i
can't remember roaming the streets
um hallucinating and wearing someone
else's clothes
and they brought him to hospital and he
promptly died and no one knows what he
was doing
uh the most likely scenario is that he
was suffering from delirium tremens
which is alcohol withdrawal which makes
you hallucinate
but um he also might have had rabies
i mean look if you're gonna you're gonna
have a mad life you might as well get
rabies
right so why not edgar allan poe like
honestly
i found his life quite inspiring because
he's very very famous
he's quite a good he's you know he's
good at what he does even though his
writing is sensationalist
and yet what a screw-up you know i
thought you meant you found him like an
inspiration and you were like i'm gonna
go marry a child
get real drunk wow edgar allan poe well
thank you very much for
elucidating uh illuminating us
about the life of someone who i think we
all just thought was a guy who wrote
about
a big old crow we are at the end of the
episode which means it's time for
freestyle rap could just use sound
effects but no using my mouth uh
freestyle rap
based on things that we've mentioned in
the show news stories from the week
alice is gonna do them rather than
giving them all up top i'm gonna drop
beat i want you to just throw them at me
while we're going is that all
all good and all cool okay right be
about to drop give me the first
suggestion
aoc in a bikini cool i'm at the beach
within my reach a lady who thinks that
trump should be
impeached she knows it's me that's the
aoc and they're covering a body a bikini
not a one piece
that we like to do you gotta split it in
the middle of fabric so it's two
made by the a.i the algorithm you can
get it on
and i rhyme with precision andrew
jackson an american debt
don't forget 1835 he'd be wiping out the
debt
getting rid of all of it we're
preferring this all the modern day
fiscal conservatives i like yeah 735
million we need to cut it down be
thriving thrifty
nifty that's aj still a bad guy in many
other ways
writing it all off you can just come in
there's no need to pause polite you
should go
in before me like your whole
feminization of chinese men
chinese kids they adore wearing all the
dresses
growing tresses long xi jinping in
charges like it's wrong i don't like all
the little boys turning into the ladies
i can see them all wearing more pink
lately so
we'll try and make them more masculine
more hench like the working out with the
square chin
i know he sounds like a cockney but i
won't do a chinese accent so
my throat spread like these ones yeah
it's pretty sick when i spit with the
diameter like bread lick
diameter like the width of a circle now
i talk about the diameter it's hurtful
my name is chris i do the wrap i want a
drink
i turn the tap i put it in my mouth and
then i'll go away
if you are hungry like a cow hey just
creep down to the bread factory
have a little lick on the loaf actually
like yum yum
flavor in my head i'm a bovine beast and
i lick the bread
bringing all the blues and the reds and
the democrats republicans like a donkey
elephant is hella fat it's hella sick to
think that you could do it
as a kind of governance system don't
pursue it it never really works
he didn't get a single vote mitch
mcconnell's there saying
now look here joe i tried to do his
voice i can only do his chin because it
looks like this with
just noises tiny reptiles all have a
smile on the madagascan i'll see a tiny
reptile madagascar animated movie it'd
be sillier than the sequel to
two millimeter not like a gun
three times justin trudeau committing
those crimes not
just the brown face but claiming all the
vaccines saying no
boy he gave you money give it back
please we want to vaccinate our
population
uh even giving maple syrup would
implicate him aye
well done hey look at that thank you
very much alice wynn
um that is the end of the show we should
also say uh for those of you
uh who again like alice don't read the
news very sadly
um so captain tom moore who we mentioned
last week was ill with coronavirus
uh sadly passed away very soon
afterwards
um yeah
thoughts and commiserations
commiserations with the wrong word
but uh thoughts with with his family and
thoughts
not with boris johnson who jumped on it
as a pr stunt and said let's all have a
clap for captain tom mortar
good british bravery and resilient
absolutely
like oh yeah as someone point out they
made him they made him their mascot
essentially
which is pretty gross but um yeah
obviously a
very sad occurrence but a long life and
uh
became gq's first uh oldest oldest color
star
he's not as sexy as he usually goes for
is he no i don't think they were
foregrounding his sexuality honestly i
think it's really
really typical of you to assume that a
man is just a sexual object
this is disgusting men are for more than
that
um that is it for the show thank you for
listening if you uh want to find out
more about alice
you can find me on instagram at let them
ebooks with underscores instead of
spaces
and you can find out about me chris
turner comedy on instagram or chris pj
turner on youtube
please do um subscribe if you've enjoyed
it give a little rating or review on the
apple podcast
app it is much appreciated share it with
a friend who'll be like i don't
understand who is this person
his wife's really interesting but he
what is he going to do oh he does a wrap
okay i see why you like that
um thank you for listening and uh enjoy
your lovely little week
[Music]
goodbye